sự đồng hành trong hôn nhân.
Trong video, cô zo biết hàng gây ấn tượng với giọng hát nội lực,
zo cảm xúc trong khi chú dễ tương thang lại khiến khu khí chở nên sôi động khí xen và những đoạn gặp.
Sự kết hợp bất nở như an ý này nhé trong đốn tin người xem,
khi em anh, thở trân điểm cho cô zo, đồng thời là người đang tải video, cho hay tiếp mục nhận được sử hưởng
cũng của đồng đảo hết mời.
Cô đã làm nghề nhiều năm và tưởng thân sự không ít đáng cưới,
nhưng tiếp mục cuộc gặp đôi này để lại ấn tượng đặc biệt.
Chơi sẻ với phong viên, chú dễ tương thang cho biết,
bản thân khá bất nở trước sự quan tâm từ cộng đồng mà.
Chúng tôi chính ít đơn giản là muốn có một tích mục phương.